Gotham's law breaking taxi drivers he
overlooks a reality bending layout and
Alicia silverstone's hilariously genuine
mispronunciation keep watching for some
of the best movie mistakes that made it
into the Final Cut
a good soldier fights through Peril and
injury and apparently so does a good
actor you've probably heard of a number
of performers who do their own stunts
but George MacKay never expected one
particular scene from the 2019 War film
1917 to put him on that list while his
character's grueling Sprint at the end
of the film was undoubtedly an intense
climax to his mission the actor wasn't
meant to take any hits as he ran across
the battlefield he had come out of
rehearsal for the scene unscathed but
there are no guarantees of timing in
such a complex scene on the actual day
of shooting as Makai told Jimmy Fallon
he found himself taking multiple blows
from a slew of oncoming soldiers despite
never having rehearsed the shot that way
yeah well that's like that's a mistake
that made it in that wasn't meant to
happen but an actor keeps going until
the director calls for a cut and for
such an important moment in the film he
knew he couldn't throw in the towel
himself so he kept moving and director
Sam Mendes never halted the take he must
have realized that despite deviating
from rehearsal something even more
intense was happening the shot that was
never meant to happen ended up being one
of the greatest triumphs of makai's
performance
while filming The Princess Bride Carrie
El was convinced Christopher Guest to
hit him on the head with the pommel of
his sword in a scene I swear it will be
done this action was scripted but the
issue arose because they apparently
didn't have a rubber prop sword to do
the deed harmlessly Elwes thought it
would turn out fine if they just used a
real one of course he expected his
co-star to give him a gentle tap
certainly not the level of bludgeoning
you'd rather have a stuntman step in for
but guests apparently didn't know his
own strength it's part of the story for
elwez's character Wesley to get KO so
you might never have known the actor had
really been knocked unconscious if not
for an interview eloes gave to Sundance
TV describing the incident he said that
the next thing he knew he was waking up
in the hospital the blow actually ended
up creating a literal slapstick comedy
moment that made it into the film and
served its trademark zaniness incredibly
well every job has its hazards if you
work in a kitchen you run the risk of
slipping on spills or burning yourself
with hot cooking oil if you work in an
office you might get carpal tunnel
syndrome and if you're Channing Tatum
portraying Olympic wrestler Mark Schultz
and Bennett Miller's 2014 film Fox
catcher you might break your hand pop
your eardrum and cut your head open all
of these injuries actually befell
Channing Tatum during the shooting of
foxcatcher he broke his hand while
training for the role but you can see
the other two mishaps during the film
when Mark ruffalo's character roughs up
tatums and clips him on the air you see
Tatum wince his eardrum actually popped
in this moment and when Tatum slams his
head into a mirror the cut you see on
his head in the film is real the actor
went a little too hard in the moment and
actually broke through the wall behind
the prop glass so when you see the
intensity of Channing Tatum's physical
reactions in foxcatcher you're often
seeing something all too real perhaps
his most telling line from a variety
interview on the subject eardrums heal
so I'm fine
sometimes you do the spit take and
sometimes the spit takes you or
something like that this mistake in the
Martian is another case in which part of
the action was scripted but a mishap
actually elevated it to the next level
the Martian is directed by Ridley Scott
a Sci-Fi Legend who's apparently known
for getting scenes done in just a few
takes this is opposed to the dozens of
attempts that other directors might
often employ to get things just right
his films are said to be full of banana
peels because if someone accidentally
slips and messes up or eats it as Donald
Glover puts it the clumsiness just makes
it all the more real Scott prefers this
humanizing element so he doesn't bother
doing the scene over just because
someone tripped and you'll often see
such unscripted stumbles in his films in
this particular instance a nervous
Glover slips and falls on some spilled
coffee that he himself had spit out
earlier into a waste basket he gets up
saying is fine and stays in character to
complete the scene the spitting out was
scripted it but the slipping was not so
Glover was quite surprised when after
the scene all Ridley Scott had to say
was that was great
actors like Channing Tatum and Donald
Glover didn't have to go to the hospital
for their injuries and slip-ups but some
performers weren't as lucky Brad Pitt's
character in David Fincher 7 actually
had to be changed to accommodate his arm
injury which he sustained during a chase
scene he accidentally put his arm
Through a Windshield after a scripted
fall from a fire escape the star even
required surgery for this wound from
that point on in the film Pitt's
character is always wearing a cast which
required Fincher to alter many other
sequences in the movie to accommodate
the injury these scenes weren't just the
ones that in the film's chronology came
after the chase scene after all movies
don't always shoot their scenes in the
same order as they appear in the story
so there were a lot of scenes from
before the chase that hadn't been shot
yet and Fincher had to hide Pit's arm in
these moments to disguise the injury as
it hadn't happened yet in the world of
the story in film just because something
is unscripted that doesn't mean that
it's a mistake some directors are pretty
strict about improvisation While others
encourage it on the actor's end some
improvised moments work much better than
others but even the ones that don't go
over well are typically conscious acting
choices not accidents in the case of
this sequence from Captain America the
First Avenger you could say it was an
improvisation and that'd be partly true
but it's still definitely qualifies as a
mistake when you hear Haley Atwell tell
it in what Vanity Fair describes as your
favorite scene in Captain America at
Will's Peggy Carter sees Chris Evans
super soldier serum saturated Steve
Rogers with his shirt off for the first
time she reaches out in awe and
seemingly involuntarily touches his
chest but this wasn't only Peggy's first
time seeing Steve shirtless it was also
at Will's first time seeing Evan's
shirtless the actress said that she was
compelled to impulsively touch Chris
Evans chest and the director apparently
thought it was so organic that you can
see it in the film by her account it was
less of a choice in character and more
compulsion in the moment as herself
practical an accident but what a happy
accident it was at well for her Parts
claimed that it was the highlight of her
life
you think that being in the background
of the film means you're missing out on
all the action that's not necessarily
the case sometimes you get even more
action than you bargained for and it's
not always a pleasant or star-making
experience but you can rely on the
eagle-eyed film enthusiasts of Reddit to
eventually get you the recognition you
deserve for taking a background blow
like a champ blink and you'll miss it
but when Tom Cruise Dismounts his horse
in one scene in The Last Samurai the
Steed kicks an extra in the crutch you
can tell from his reaction that it
wasn't some sort of stunt but once you
see it it's all the more impressive that
the extra remains standing and though he
stumbles a bit takes it like a true
warrior what's most alarming is that no
one around him appears to Flinch when it
happens or check to make sure that he's
okay if you want to believe the best you
could read the lack of response as
evidence of the stoicism of the soldiers
either way the injured Soldier is a true
champ
imagine your first chest waxing and your
first leading role in a film occurring
at the very same time it sounds like
it'd be a lot of pressure and that
things could potentially go really badly
that's exactly what happened to Steve
Carell his character in the 40 year old
virgin Andy is trying to get into the
dating world for the first time and as
the title of the film suggests lose his
virginity he gets a lot of advice from
some pretty questionable but
well-meaning sources which ultimately
leads to him booking a waxing
appointment oh that sounds like it would
be nice normally it seemed like this
would be done with makeup and special
effects but Corel thought it would be
better if the waxing was real he assumed
it wouldn't hurt that badly but you can
tell in the scene itself how shocked he
is at his miscalculation the pain is
real to make matters worse the actor who
played his waxer lied about being
experienced in the procedure and
apparently skipped an important
protective step that is applying vessel
lean to his nipples poor Steve the
master of physical comedy really went to
his limits this time and thankfully it's
not completely embarrassing rather it's
a hilarious and memorable scene and the
film wouldn't be the same without it
have you ever noticed that in many
scenes in the MCU movies Tony Stark is
munching on some sort of snack it's easy
to believe that it's just part of his
character he's quirky in many other ways
and always does whatever he wants so why
should the end of the world keep him
from snacking well apparently this habit
was never part of Stark's character in
the beginning Robert Downey Jr would
just hide snacks all over the set and
randomly start munching out during takes
without telling anyone he was going to
there was nothing anyone could do about
it since they never knew when it was
going to happen so the production just
made constantly eating and drinking a
comedic part of Iron Man's Cavalier
character and honestly it fits just fine
is it a mistake it would have been for a
lesser actor as it likely would have
gotten them fired or at least heavily
reprimanded but RDJ took his snacking
and made a meal out of it a series of
mistakes in Titanic turned out to be a
blessing in disguise Believe It or Not
Jack's now famous exclamation at the tip
of the ship wasn't originally in the
script in fact he and director James
Cameron had tried a bunch of different
lines in its place and they all fell
flat time was running out and the
production was losing light but finally
after a bunch of mistake lines an
exasperated Cameron told DiCaprio to
just say I'm king of the world and
apparently DiCaprio really didn't want
to at the time responding to Cameron's
Direction with an unconvinced what and
repeating the question when Cameron
reiterated his instructions to the
second objection Cameron simply replied
with quote just sell it we're
eternally grateful that the previous
scripted attempts turned out to be
mistakes mistakes that in their wake
made room for one of the most
recognizable lines in one of Cinema's
most revered films we'd love to know
what some of those failed lines were
though
when the futuristic bat Vehicles
dominate the screen in the Dark Knight
trilogy most people really aren't paying
attention to much else but if you check
the traffic in the background there are
quite a few scenes in which Gotham
citizens don't appear to be obeying
traffic rules these sequences usually
occur in high speed quickly cut chasings
so they're easy to miss and if we're
being honest a little nitpicky to point
out even if you do catch them still the
other drivers on the road as the Caped
Crusader rides his Bat pod after the
Joker are blatantly ignoring street
lights of course the taxi drivers who
nearly crash into the bat pod and honk
as he whizzes through them are most
likely stunt drivers given how close
they come to colliding with him not to
mention that these near encounters were
great to emphasize the Peril of the
chase but if you look closely the lights
facing left and right where the vehicles
come from are red these collisions
should have never happened you could
nitpick and say it ruins the realism but
we disagree the whole premise of Nolan's
Trilogy is that Gotham is a city of
debauchery Mayhem and moral bankruptcy
there's often explicit debate as to
whether it can be saved we naturally
conceive of that in Epic cinematic terms
Grand scale sociopaths like the Joker
corrupt officials at the highest levels
and sky-high crime rates but if Gotham
truly is a lawless City wouldn't that
extend to every area of life if people
aren't going to follow the law when it
comes to fraud murder and greed why
would they when it comes to traffic
many injuries are the result of talented
invested actors taking their scripted
scenes a little too far it's a testament
to their acting that they're willing to
risk a bodily injury in order to fully
inhabit a scene but we hope they don't
make a tradition out of needing stitches
in Nightcrawler Jake Gyllenhaal plays
the freelance photojournalist named Lou
who enters the competitive business of
covering violent incidents like crashes
and crimes and selling the footage to
news stations naturally he develops an
unsettling obsession with his work and
uses increasingly questionable means to
obtain the most compelling footage
before any of his competitors this means
going so far as to tamper with crime
scenes and manipulate police journalists
and criminals it goes without saying
that the guy is intense at one point he
punches a mirror which was part of the
script Jake Gyllenhaal needing stitches
in his hand afterward though that was
not part of the plan even still it all
fits incredibly well with a CD character
who will go to any links to to get what
he wants you might have been told as a
kid that Sugar can make your teeth fall
out but for one young extra in Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory this
threat became all too real in an
unexpected way when confectionary
magnate Willy Wonka announces his golden
ticket sweepstakes it inspires a frenzy
as people everywhere flock to candy
stores in hopes of finding a ticket in
one scene a crown of children clamor at
the counter of a sweet shop the
proprietor while singing the now famous
the Candyman tune graciously invites the
children behind the counter to select
their treats but if you watched closely
he almost knocks one little girl's teeth
out this moment hasn't been spoken about
in interviews likely in Parks because
the film vastly predated internet
discourse on such subjects but it's a
very small chance the sequence was
scripted or directed this way you can
see from the clip that the little girl
actually gets clogged by the fold-up
counter it's pretty safe to assume that
they didn't plan for this and then bring
a six-year-old stunt girl on set to get
nailed in the face what makes this goof
so perfect though is how the little girl
doesn't seem phased at all she still
rushes past the counter to get at the
candy it makes her seem so hilariously
invested in the treats that she doesn't
notice getting hit on the chin and she
won't be the last child in the film
whose dogged pursuit of sweets gets her
into trouble
while it's also full of all the sweetest
things in life Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory has more than one
mistake hidden under the wrapper and one
continuity error in this film
accidentally makes a pretty powerful
statement when the malnourished Charlie
eats what's probably his first ever
Wonka bar we see him take a bite in one
shot while his mouth is already stuffed
but in the next shot just a couple of
seconds later his mouth is totally empty
you can't swallow almost an entire
chocolate bar in a matter of seconds it
definitely can't be done without making
a mess or at least needing to catch
one's breath afterwards at first glance
this is an extremely minor continuity
error and again since this is a viewer
caught slip up in an old film it hasn't
been addressed as a mistake by anyone
connected with the feature we're just
deferring to the laws of physics here
but on that note this mistake can
totally be spun as the Whimsical film's
magical realist take on just how
ravenous Charlie is for the first ever
take of Wonka chocolate in his
impoverished life
the layout of the Overlook Hotel in The
Shining Stanley Kubrick's film
adaptation of Stephen King's disquieting
horror novel is spatially impossible if
you try to match what you see inside the
hotel with what you see on the exterior
there's simply no way to make it work
but when you think about the story
itself everything about the Sinister
seemingly sentient Hotel defies logic
and is meant to confuse the viewer and
occupants and drive them slowly mad so
why not the architecture itself some
people staunchly argue that The Shining
set features many impossibilities from
Windows that shouldn't exist doors that
lead nowhere to entire rooms that
couldn't possibly fit inside the hotel
others however say it's all part of
Kubrick's genius and that the hotel
itself is clearly a supernatural
disorienting Force an illusion in and of
itself in many ways it would certainly
lend new and unsettling meaning to the
now famous sequences of Danny riding his
tricycle through the Byzantine twists
and turns of the hotel's hallways he may
be wheeling in and out of reality
self-absorbed share living up to the
title of the film clueless mispronounces
words throughout the movie but what you
might not know is that actress Alicia
Silverstone herself is making these
errors whenever you hear her articulate
a word slightly wrong there's a good
chance that the mistake is genuine
Apparently after Silverstone had made a
few mistakes in the debate scene members
of the Clueless cast and crew attempted
to help her out by correcting her
however director Amy heckerling called
for everyone to stand down she felt that
mispronouncing Haitians as Haitians is
something shares ditzy and self-absorbed
character would totally do so if the
government could just get to the kitchen
rearrange some things we could certainly
party with the hadians and she was
absolutely right Cher's
mispronunciations serve as foreshadowing
for the growth she will experience over
the course of the movie that is from the
selfish ignorant girl she once was to
the conscientious caring person she
always had the potential to be and these
competing elements wouldn't have been
expressed as well without those
delightful mispronunciations
bloopers are just a part of doing
business well not business is Show
Business actors are bound to mess up a
line every now and then or after a long
day on set improvise and make their
co-stars laugh while most of these flubs
and Goofs are innocent some are
downright ronjay for example Full House
has there ever been a more innocuous TV
show than Full House the often
sickeningly sweet sitcom used its ah
track almost as often as its last track
but two of its cast members were veteran
standups both quick on their feet and
even occasionally pretty filthy in this
blooper Dave Coulier really lets Bob
Saget have it but apologizes to another
character off camera
really see how little your dick is in
that suit
sorry Patty sorry Patty I'm sorry Bob
Bob got arrested my weiner sorry Patty
friends the friends of friends were well
friends and when people are that close
both in friendship and proximity there's
bound to be the occasional bit of
accidental nudity it's even a plot line
that was actually scripted on friends at
least a couple of times but this is not
one of those times oh whoa one hand on
the cheek joke
you saw it didn't you
The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air in this
blooper from the otherwise classy sitcom
The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air Colton is
supposed to be concentrating really hard
but he looks like he's doing something
else so somebody in the sound booth
sweetened the shot
go on try it
the Soupy Sales show soupy was a beloved
Kitty TV host in the early days of TV
but one day his crew surprised him in
the middle of a taping with an R-rated
special guest behind an onset door
wow
yes
and uh though right now uh let's have a
couple of commercials 30 Rock Will
Arnett had a recurring role on 30 Rock
as Devin Banks and nefarious and
sometimes predatory NBC executive with
his eye on the innocent page Kenneth his
flirting could get a little creepy and
alarming such as when he force-fed
Kenneth a bottle of apple juice and
arnott's Roofing got a little too out of
hand God your mouth is so thirsty
such a thirsty man Better Off Ted this
quirky ABC sitcom aired for just two
seasons but it quickly became a cold hit
for its surreal and twisted take on
office culture in one episode a typo in
a memo requires rather than discourages
employees of the show's workplace to use
offensive or insulting language this led
to some pretty insane outtakes as the
actors and writers kept trying to one-up
each other he is just a sample I'm
terrible at insults I can help you you
Mouse humping pieces I can help you use
sweaty thong and a hooker's money crack
could you repeat that in English I don't
speak the language of the square puppets
drugs and Recreation a tremendous cast
of Comedy All-Stars kept things loose
and improvised from time to time on the
set of NBC's small town government
comedy Parks and Recreation but Chris
Pratt in particular had a difficult time
not crossing the line such as in this
scene where the gang pretends to be old
people to better empathize with them
when I sit down and do my dirty business
my gonad's handle in the water
TV is a whole lot better than it used to
be over the past decade or so so-called
Prestige TV has offered audiences superb
acting cinematic style unpredictable
storylines and an epic scope never
before seen on the small screen many of
these shows are serious sometimes
devastating dramas with important things
to say birth even brilliant Productions
like these crank out plenty of
ridiculous and hilarious bloopers and
outtakes Breaking Bad child actors are
unpredictable and the younger they are
the more unpredictable they can be but
Productions only have a limited time
each day to use babies so they can't
wait around for when the baby feels like
acting especially since they don't
really know their acting nor do they
care take this Breaking Bad outtake for
example in which the infant playing
Holly white makes some very interesting
choices for her character kids they they
are safe of course they are
I don't think she feels very safe Game
of Thrones in this blooper from HBO's
fantasy epic Game of Thrones kit
Harrington plays the corpse of Jon Snow
his body laid out on a table for what
will ultimately be his spooky
Resurrection from the dead snow was
supposed to be naked in this scene with
only a modest genital concealing garment
preventing anyone on set from seeing
Little John
[Music]
Deadwood
so many gag reels consist of actors for
getting their lines and swearing up a
storm but what happens on a show like
HBO's gritty Western Deadwood in which
half of the dialogue is already swearing
the actor simply burst into a song or at
least that's what happens when apparent
Rolling Stones fan Ian McShane can't
remember what comes after a line that
includes the word start me
don't start me
Don't Stop Me Oh Start Me Up and you
stop me up you're whipped me up you put
me down Sons of Anarchy there's a lot of
platonic male and male affection on Sons
of Anarchy especially in the form of
backslapping bro hugs but while shooting
one of the show's many action sequences
actor Ryan Hurst overestimates how far
he needs to move and winds up unusually
close to his fellow gun toting
cover-seeking co-star Charlie Hunnam
what do you want for Christmas
Hannibal Brian Fuller's artfully gory
television adaptation of Thomas Harris's
Hannibal Lecter novels featured many
scenes of its Central cannibalistic
serial killer intricately preparing
gourmet meals in his beautiful kitchen a
lot of that was likely achieved through
the magic of editing because in this
blooper actor Moss Mickelson can't quite
Master the show off the knife skills
that would be second nature to the
character
three
[Music]
vended it in the 19th century
Criminal Minds despite the gruesome
subject matter of Criminal Minds it
looks like the cast and crew keep things
pretty light and loose on set he's no
longer with the show but Thomas Gibson
seemed to have a pretty good time while
he was starring on the long-running CBS
crime procedural like the time it took
him a comically long time to put a pair
of rubber gloves on
you know your prostate is about the
right size for a man your age
Lauren order as for you when you're
making a long-running crime series about
the most appalling of crimes allowing
yourself to laugh here and there on set
is a good way for actors to cope with
the depressing material case in point
former Law and Order SVU star
Christopher Maloney can't get over how
funny it is and how utterly creepy he
sounds to ask a suspect for something
rather unusual would you mind if we took
a DNA swab from a church mouth
even I felt creepy would you mind if we
took a DNA swab from inside your mouth
it'll help us even I I felt creepy again
ER the hmbc hospital drama ER made
George Clooney a superstar and not long
after he became one of the biggest movie
stars on the planet he also had a unique
way of coming up with some dialogue in
the events that he forgot to line while
filming the incredibly fast-paced show
I'm gonna try someone should close your
eyes I want you to think of
think of me with no clothes on would you
just shut up and kiss me kiss me Orphan
Black Tatiana Maslany plays many
different clones on Orphan Black but
they're all pretty different for example
Alison Hendricks is a high strung Taipei
kind of person Sarah Manning is a
self-sufficient and StreetWise Rogue and
the Ukrainian clone Helena always seems
to have really bad things happen to her
in this scene there's a scorpion that's
supposed to be crawling all over Helena
but masloni just can't keep it together
in the 1990s Jim Carrey became one of
the biggest stars in the world thanks to
hit films like Ace Ventura Pet Detective
Dumb and Dumber the mask and liar liar
he's an incredibly likable actor and
also a very loose performer he
improvises a lot so when you combine
that with his manic energy it results in
lots of unexpected moments of him
cracking up his co-stars and himself
here are some behind the scenes clips
from Jim Carrey movies outtakes so good
that they could have been in the movies
themselves
Almighty then
Bruce Almighty is a high concept
Blockbuster where Carrie stars is a TV
reporter who gets to take a crack at
being God in this blooper an agitated
Bruce has to cut off a conversation
because he's running late for work
generally actors who have to drive in
movies don't actually drive instead the
car is placed on a rig so that the crew
can control exactly where it goes this
outtake reveals that secret as Carrie
fiddles with the controls and pretends
to zoom out of the neighborhood
foreign
Poppin with the penguins
Mr Popper's Penguins Stars Carrie as a
guy who opens up his apartment to dozens
of The Tuxedo colored polar birds for
many of the shots the production used
real penguins and they've got genuine
comedic chops in this outtake Carrie
attempts to establish comic rapport with
a prickly penguin who reluctantly
obliges first the bird completely
ignores his attempts at friendliness
then when he attempts the old it's for
you bit with a phone the Little Critter
amusingly snaps its beak as a clever
retort I'll introduce you somebody wants
to talk
[Music]
oh yeah
water in the court
in Liar Liar Carrie plays a sleazy
lawyer who is physically unable to say
anything but the truth ironically enough
in this outtake the joke is based on a
lie after an exchange with co-star
Jennifer Tilly Kerry pours himself a
glass of water from a pitcher he knows
that neither the glass nor the pitcher
is going to appear on screen but that
the sound will register so it's the
perfect opportunity for Carrie to make
it seem like he's relieving himself in
the courtroom foreign
[Music]
something about Merry Christmas
In This Moment from Dumb and Dumber 2
best friends Harry Dunn and Lloyd
Christmas are having one of their little
arguments in the outtake Carrie adds
some highly theatrical laughing his
co-star Jeff Daniels doesn't break
character instead managing to improvise
this line
yeah yeah uh yeah okay let me just laugh
some more no cause I can't remember my
life something about marriage it's a
joke that works on two levels
referencing both the name of Lloyd's
unattainable dream woman from the
original Dumb and Dumber as well as
another very successful fairly Brothers
film
hello Clarice Kerry departed from his
wheelhouse of likable idiots in the 1996
dark comedy the cable guy he plays a TV
installer who befriends a regular guy
and then stalks him and tries to ruin
his life one of the movie's most famous
scenes takes place at Medieval Times
Carrie puts a bunch of meat on his face
and references Hannibal Lecter from The
Silence of the Lambs it was apparently
so funny to Carrie and Matthew Broderick
that they struggled to film the scene
without cracking up
of the Lamb
yes
fun with gym and props Jim Carrey knows
a thing or two about physical comedy but
that doesn't necessarily mean he's the
most physically coordinated actor in
this outtake from Fun with Dick and Jane
Harry Suburban dad turned criminal is
supposed to celebrate a successful phone
call by throwing the phone from one hand
to the other but he can't quite seem to
pull it off as he drops the phone and
sends it flying when he actually does
manage to catch it he pauses to savor
the moment but for so long that the take
is unusable
oh
a series of fortunate riffs A Series of
Unfortunate Events is based on Lemony
Snicket's Gothic children's novel about
the orphan vaudelaire children with
Carrie as villainous Master of Disguise
Count Olaf there ended up being plenty
of extra footage in this clip he
improvises a song about a time machine
that leads him to imitating a clock gone
mad which then leads to his top-notch
dinosaur impression somehow his co-stars
continue to pretend to sleep even as he
runs around and well does this
foreign
what's my name again
Anchorman 2 did everything the first
Anchorman did only much bigger and said
in the 80s instead of the 70s this
included revisiting the first film's
epic news anchor Battle Royale the
original fight featured only local San
Diego news teams while the second
increased the stakes with national and
international squads there were cameos
Galore including Carrie and Marion Cody
yard as a Canadian Duo though Kerry is a
native Canuck his characters exaggerated
accent made it hard for him to spit out
his lines what that hell's my name Scott
Riley there's not gonna be a fight
without Ron what's my name my name is
not Ron whether he's playing a Jedi or
the director of Shield Samuel L Jackson
always follows his instincts and those
instincts are often funny
sometimes though his jokes aren't
entirely on purpose that leads to some
outrageous bloopers and outtakes both
for himself and his co-stars here are
some times when he cut loose Nick Fury
is a serious serious man Samuel L
Jackson you know not so much but the guy
is such a professional he manages to
keep it serious even when everyone else
around him is screwing up why am I going
over here to see him on the thing and
tell him you know but why did I do don't
be going all stealth mode we can't see
you
the 2017 action flick The hitman's
Bodyguard gave fans a chance to see
Deadpool and Nick Fury together at last
well at least the actors who played them
so it's no surprise that there were a
lot of casualties in the film what is a
surprise is that there were some
casualties behind the scenes as well
such as this poor dude
[Laughter]
poor Mace Windu he should have been the
ultimate hero but instead he got blown
out a window thanks to Anakin's Betrayal
at least Jackson was able to have some
fun with it though filming it over and
over again while pretending the safety
mat was a big comfy mattress and his
death was just a bad dream
even though he's known for playing a guy
with one eye Jackson seems to have
amazing peripheral vision or something
because in this blooper from xXx the
return of Xander cage he seems to know
exactly what's happening behind him
because soldiers are built to take
orders and fight Wars but wait my friend
are not at War
behind us
it can't be easy for Maria Hill the
deputy director of Shield under
Taskmaster Nick Fury and it can't be
easy for actress Kobe smolders either as
like Fury himself Jackson is always
watching and ready to pounce on any
screw-up I got confused with my eyeline
I think I looked directly into camera I
don't care you just forgot to learn now
you're trying to make up some others
in the 2003 action flick SWAT Jackson
plays a Los Angeles Police Department
Sergeant tasked with putting together an
Elite Force but only if he can keep his
balance first heard some rumors about
you and your old partner
just like in swat Samuel L Jackson plays
a tough as Nails cop in the 2010 comedy
the other guys and like and SWAT gravity
is his downfall that's in the fact that
co-star Dwayne The Rock Johnson seems to
have no idea what Jackson is doing
whoops tuck and roll when you hit me
books
for all the blood pumping brawls
sentimental scenes and general Doom and
Gloom seen on screen in Avengers
Infinity War there was just as much
laughter banter and Goofs that played
out behind the scenes and thanks to the
Blu-ray release of infinity War which
features a two minute long gag reel
viewers at home can witness the best of
those bloopers in one handy spot
something wrong with Wong after Bruce
Banner crashed lands at the New York
sanctum following his Cosmic Face-Off
with Thanos he meets up with Iron Man
Wong and Doctor Strange Wong and Doctor
Strange give a crash course on the
Infinity Stones Bruce explains just how
Wicked Thanos is and Iron Man goes to
call Captain America for help hoping to
reconcile after the falling out in
Captain America Civil War but when Iron
Man notices that the wind has picked up
the four men slowly turned to face the
sanctum Street side door and realized
that thanos's lieutenants have already
touched down on Earth pretty dramatic
stuff right well during filming actor
Benedict Wong couldn't really keep it
that way
[Music]
bumbling Benedict and mush-mouth Mark
they may be two of the smartest
characters in the entire Marvel
Cinematic Universe but for a few minutes
during filming Avengers Infinity War Dr
Strange and Bruce Banner definitely
acted like a couple of doofuses when
Bruce and Doctor Strange emerged from a
portal and greet Iron Man and pepper
pots in the Park actors Benedict
Cumberbatch and Mark Ruffalo seem to
forget how to like talk and stuff
I'm Dr I'm Doctor I can't walk at the
moment
Infinity war is some of the other
superheroes but a lack of narrative
influence doesn't equate to a lack of
quality bloopers during the battle in
wakanda Falcon soars through the sky to
take down the black order and the
outriders between takes Mackie made sure
to paint a great mental picture for
everyone of what his scene would look
like when the movie was finished flying
about 80 miles an hour just a big
chocolate missile when shooting another
portion of the wakanda battle Mackie had
another important acting moment this
time with co-director Joe Russo hey
Russo you want me to go Jamie Foxx on
this one
oh everybody put on your sunglasses
Denzel's coming out and that wasn't the
only time Mackie discussed his acting
process between takes during the film's
intense final sequence Falcon rests
slumped on the wakandan forest floor
it's a heartbreaking moment for viewers
turns out it's because Mackie was
channeling his Infinity War co-star Don
war machine cheetle for inspiration I'm
going for a Cheeto on this take oh
don't give a bullet cheese black panther
versus the bleeding goats poised yet
passionate and undeniably Powerful
Chadwick boseman's t'challa better known
as black panther is generally able to
keep his cool under even the worst of
situations this Rings especially true in
Infinity War when Black Panther gives
Sebastian Stan's war-weathered Bucky
Barnes and new bionic arm and subtly
asked him to join the resistance against
Thanos whose black order was minutes
away from Landing in wakanda
this one may be tired of what with a
white wolf has arrested long enough upon
seeing his upgrade Bucky and black
panther have a simple dramatic exchange
where's the fight
on its way
the blooper reel features an extended
version of this moment Which is less
dramatic the problem a couple of extras
just couldn't keep quiet during filming
specifically two chatty goats
I know you have found something
a sense of Peace
okay now you are going too far now
a hairy situation nearing the third Act
of the film Black Widow Bruce Banner
Captain America Scarlet Witch Falcon War
Machine Envision all traveled to wakanda
to visit shuri the genius younger sister
of t'challa who's known for advanced
technological Creations like the latest
version of the Black Panther suit the
group hopes that Shari can safely and
successfully remove the Mind Stone from
vision's forehead and that they can
destroy it before Thanos seizes it and
uses it to power The Infinity Gauntlet
snap his fingers and kill half the
universe once in the Lush futuristic
country the heroes wind up preparing to
battle the purple muscle despot with
black widow joining the fight inside a
ship alongside wakandan Warriors and
members of the Dora milaje like so many
scenes throughout the film this sequence
was shot in front of a green screen but
also required the use of a machine to
simulate real wind whipping past and the
Machine kind of worked a little too well
both in this scene and in one starring
Elizabeth Olsen as the Scarlet Witch
from earlier in the film
because you're worth it
if they ever get tired of acting
Johansson Olson and the rest of the
infinity War cast could totally do
shampoo commercials instead no matter
what other movies or TV shows Mark
Hamill makes he will always be
synonymous with one role Luke Skywalker
that's just bound to happen when an
actor's breakout gig turns out to be the
lead role in the original Star Wars
films Star Wars fans love Hamill for
being a part of their favorite movies
but he's also one of the most
accomplished voice actors in Hollywood
surprise
in addition to Bringing dozens of
characters to life Hamel is also a funny
and fun-loving Guy these bloopers from
behind the scenes of his films prove it
training day when Star Wars first came
along nobody had ever seen anything like
it including the cast and crew with all
kinds of ridiculous costumes and sci-fi
props to work with things tended to get
a little silly on set
well
and they only got worse when they
started playing around with lightsabers
while we've had the luxury of decades to
make fun of lightsabers Mark Hamill and
director George Lucas had to create
those iconic moves from scratch he'd
certainly never waved a laser sword
around before so the process of him
learning how to do it in these outtakes
makes him look very uncool but it still
packs a lot of charm
super what
Star Wars is a science fiction movie set
in space with lots of ships star bases
and alien races which means it's loaded
up with lots of made-up jargon as Luke
Skywalker Mark Hamill certainly got his
fair share of mumbo jumbo mouthfuls
basically from the beginning but I was
going into Toshi station to pick up some
power inverters that's in the medium
range of difficult slang but in this
blooper from Star Wars Hamill has a hard
time getting down a simple line that's
laced with just one space word now let's
get some distance
Supernova what inflection Supernova or
supernova no Lions no problem
in 1994 Mark Hamill took a break from
his usual roles to starring the space
simulator game Wing Commander 3 heart of
the tiger the game was one of the first
to make full use of the then Cutting
Edge technology a full motion video
which puts Hamill front and center in
most of the cutscenes
Wing Commander 3 featured over two hours
of that kind of thing which meant a lot
of time in front of the camera for the
actors considering the nature of the
project it's no surprise that things
could get a little out of hand I'm ready
to add to that Legend now that you're
here
to his credits Hummel was a consummate
professional throughout the whole thing
even when he couldn't remember his lines
we've got to be on our guard
I don't know my line but I want everyone
to think I do
barely scripted Mark Hamill also shows
up from time to time in interesting
Indie movies such as brigsby bear a dark
comedy about the strangest and most
mysterious Kitty TV show possible
co-written and starring Saturday night
lives Kyle Mooney Hamill plays Ted the
father figure of Mooney's character and
also an evil human face Sun God on the
show within a movie Rigsby bear
Adventures
[Music]
Hamel is barely recognizable in the
parts however his voice and sense of
humor are immediately familiar when he
starts riffing funny things to say
calm down bro
[Music]
times and the cast of Captain Marvel was
no exception despite seasoned actors and
Oscar winners filling the movie's Ruster
lines were forgotten blocking was
totally bungled and goofiness got the
best of the Stars more often than you
might think
Brie Larson carried the weight of
Captain Marvel on his shoulders and
spent months preparing to play the
high-flying heroine as best as she
possibly could she devoted hours of her
days to working out in the gym stuck to
a strict diet and even visited the U.S
Air Force Academy for some up and close
personal priming but when Larson
acquired all that Newfound strength and
knowledge and know-how she apparently
lost an important basic skill multiple
times during filming Larson got mixed up
on the direction she was supposed to go
and what she was meant to do with her
body
[Music]
Lawson again gets directionally confused
while filming a fight scene with Talos
actor Ben Mendelssohn who also could
have used a helping hand in the blocking
Department the two rehearsed their
tussle one way but when they got in
front of the cameras everything was
backwards
other side get on the other side I know
we rehearsed it this way but it's this
way now because the best things come in
threes last and top station Anna gets
off by barreling down a hallway before
realizing that she's running in the
wrong direction
rarely do actors nail the scene in one
take their performance may be spots on
but the lighting might be totally wonky
maybe the set design is impeccable and
the mood exactly right but the line
delivery isn't seamless like we said
before no one in the movie industry is
immune to mistakes for the Captain
Marvel crew though one scene didn't just
have a single hiccup it went wrong in
almost every way imaginable the sequence
in question is the one in which brie
Larson's Carol Danvers Ben mendelssohns
Talos Samuel L Jackson's Nick Fury and
lashanna Lynch's Maria Rambo escape from
the cree Warriors and the Star Force
Squad in pursuit of Marvel's hidden
laboratory that served as a refuge
Center for displaced Scrolls on screen
the scene was Flawless but one take
turned hilariously disastrous we're
talking Road Kitten lighting mishap
whole cast-breaking character disastrous
look at this unbridled mess
foreign
[Laughter]
worst maybe most hilarious oh you bet
if you thought the blooper featuring a
real cat playing Goose was rip tickling
there are plenty of silly outtakes that
find the cast interacting with a fake
feline too one take shows Samuel Jackson
looking half sad half bemused to find
out he's shooting with a standing cut
especially since he keeps getting fur on
his nose in another Lashana Lynch can't
keep it together while Jackson holds a
focus and keeps talking to it as if it
was a real deal good kitty
that's not all the feline fun the actors
had on set in a third outtake Brie
Larson's Carol throws a proper cutter
Ben Mendelson's Talos who is deathly
afraid of goose since the cuddly
creature is actually a shape-shifting
bucket Dimension holding alien known as
a flirkin when she tosses a kitty at
Talos well see for yourselves
remember that scene in the film where
Phil Coulson and Nick Fury team up to
find out what the heck is going on after
Carol danver's crash lands on Earth you
know after she destroys a blockbuster
and brings back a pack of Scrolls
trailing behind her you'll recall that
the dynamic duo was attacked by skrulls
and did soon reveal that the Colson
sitting in the passenger seat of Fury's
car isn't The Shield rookie at all he's
really a scroll who shape-shifted into
Coulson the two fight for control of the
steering wheel with Fury ultimately
winning when he deliberately crashes the
car and kills the skrull that scene
might have been wild to watch but the
process of filming must have given the
casting crew a heaping helping of
headaches if this version of the same
scene is any indication of course oh
hold on oh
it's okay no it's not
we aren't privy to their medical
histories but judging by the Captain
Marvel Gabrielle it looks like both Brie
Larson and Ben mendelsohn might have a
serious case of sweaty Palms Larson and
Mendelson continuously drop things
during shooting ruining takes but
showing that beneath all those flashy
Prosthetics and CGI effects they're just
as human as their fans they'll take real
finds clumsiness getting the best of
Larson while filming the scene in which
Carol Danvers retrieves a tesseract from
Marvel's laboratory orbiting Earth
[Music]
slippery fingers plagued Mendelson when
he was trying to perform a cool trick
with Taylor's susceptor he can be seen
tossing it up in the air ever so
slightly but having trouble grabbing
hold of the darn thing when it comes
back down each time he attempts to move
Mendelson fumbles and the staff falls to
the ground
after bleeding repeatedly
[Music]
pops over and over again on the Captain
Marvel set Ben Mendelson brought his
silly streak to an end with a rousing
rendition of the 1960s tune release me
apparently because he was worn out from
filming and just wanted to rap for the
day peel off his facial Prosthetics
scrub away all his green scroll makeup
and relax after he ends a take Mendelson
declares a dramatic tone thank you very
much good night when no one answers back
he starts singing the opening lines of
1966 track popularized by Engelbert
humperdink because why not
Please Release Me
[Applause]
despite that not happening this round of
shooting inevitably ended with
Mendelson's where she finally being
granted and he was indeed released we're
just happy that on this particular day
he let his Golden Voice be heard
no matter the movie Chris Evans always
seems to be having a good time something
made clear by the outtakes behind the
scenes footage and bloopers is Left
Behind here are some times when Evans
just couldn't keep it together while
shooting a scene Edgar Wright Scott
Pilgrim vs The World is a Triumph of
comedy and sci-fi and the whole thing
feels like a video game without coming
across this campaign to be with his
dream girl Ramona Flowers Scott must
defeat her seven evil exes including
Lucas Lee a former skateboarder turned
gravelly voice to Macho movie actor
white enlisted actual action star Chris
Evans to play this fictional action star
although Evans is probably not as
aggressive frightening and toxic as
Lucas take for example this moment on
set when Evans are supposed to be
threatening scars and instilling deep
fear in the underdog that's kind of hard
to do when you keep losing your train of
thought and forgetting your dialogue you
are a pretty good actor
I'm more than pretty good that's not the
lie
I'm not that good long before Chris
Evans and Scarlett Johansson joined the
Avengers they'd already worked together
twice in the 2004 College Heist film the
perfect score and the 2007 adaptation of
the best-selling novel The Nanny Diaries
the future Captain America played Hayden
an upper crust Upper East Side Harvard
hearty love interest for Johansson's
Nanny the character might be cool and
calm but Evans certainly isn't he has a
tough time with wordy mouthfuls of
dialogue and as soon as you get any
closer to that building you won't be
he wound up blaming his troubles on loud
noises outside of the camera's view as
well as the fact that there were half a
dozen people running straight at him
solid excuses two most powerful objects
in comic book lore have to be mjolnir
Thor's Mighty hammer and Captain
America's nine vomable Shield as seen
throughout hundreds of comic books and
almost as many Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies cap Shield gives mjolnir a run
for its money its unique steel and
vibranium composition allows it to
absorb impact and energy alike if
Captain America ducks behind it under it
or over it he can keep himself safe from
pretty much anything in the universe
this blooper captured on the set of
Captain America the Winter Soldier
shockingly revealed the only thing so
powerful that not even this impeccable
weapon and piece of protective gear can
make it Bend to its will adore
[Music]
foreign
that Shield is just a prop and it
doesn't give Evans that umphy needs to
bust down the big door
Chris Evans just can't seem to get a
break props wise did he accidentally
offends someone in the Marvel Studios
prop Department did he skip acting with
props day in drama school for whatever
reason there were even more bloopers
involving props not cooperating with the
guy who just wants to play Captain
America with proper gravitas to his
credit Evans gives it his all in a plan
of attack
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Captain America has ever faced or ever
face on screen it seems it wriggles its
way out of Evan's control over and over
again
in Spider-Man homecoming Evans Captain
America makes a cameo appearance
starring in a short educational film
that Peter Parker watches in school it's
an arrangement that makes sense if any
Avenger is going to film a public
service announcement to remind all the
boys and girls out there to eat a
nutritious balanced lunch it's Captain
America he's a product of the 1940s when
such are Shucks G whiz kinds of PSAs for
movie cereal and radio Stars will the
norm of course this is also ridiculous
that not even Evans can get through it
with a straight face hi I'm Captain
America whether you're a student or a
soldier there's one thing that will
always give you an edge a hot lunch
it's a super dramatic pivotal moment in
Avengers Age of Ultron in a commanding
everybody pay attention tone and with
cohort Black Widow at his side suited up
ready for battle Captain America boldly
and tones Avengers but then stops it's
like he's waiting for a dramatic musical
Stinger the audience is waiting for an
assemble to finish the catchphrase but
it never comes Avengers
[Music]
it would seem Evans was pausing for
effects before delivering the classic
line he was probably just messing around
for fun because he quickly turns the
moment into a goof and the movie itself
cuts to the credits before the line
finishes acting isn't the most
physically taxing or mentally draining
job in the world but it's not without
its challenges particularly when the job
is acting in a superhero movie playing
Captain America involves a lot of
physicality for Evans he's had to do
one-on-one fight scenes and tightly
choreographed group fight scenes
pretended to operate vehicles dangled
from wires and taken on villains in
front of a green screen he also has to
run a lot Captain America is always
running to dull out good old-fashioned
American Justice to bad guys in this
take for a pulse pounding scene for
Captain America the Winter Soldier
Captain Falcon quickly hoop it up to
where they need to be but in the wrong
direction
know the good guys from the bad guys
this Avengers moment is all about sheer
chaos a climactic apocalyptic battle
rages resulting in death and destruction
these moments are among the toughest for
a film crew to commit to Celluloid as
there are so many moving Parts involved
in getting it just right that also means
a chance for something to go wrong is
much higher than it is for a simple
straightforward scene in this instance
one Chris or the other is the thing that
goes wrong his Captain America lays on
the ground a leg awkwardly hanging in
the air above him awaiting a cue from
co-star Chris Hemsworth
oh the store coming in but since Evans
is the one laying there in the
foreground of the shot he's the one who
has to take one for the team and he does
it with a laugh there's an old saying
that advisors performers to never work
with children or animals after all they
both lack the self-control of adult
humans and if they don't feel like
working they just won't here are some
films in which animals wreaked havoc
while the cameras were rolling Mr
Popper's Penguins Jim Carrey loves to
goof around on the set riffing on lines
making outrageous sounds and teasing
co-stars
oh yeah Park Park
talk it's all part of the Jim Carrey
package but if he messes around a bit
too long not all of Mr Popper's penguins
are gonna put up with it I'll introduce
you somebody wants to talk
I say hi
yep oh yeah
okay you know what sometimes we need a
little hey come here come here no
Outlander
this historical TV series is full of
serious dramatic moments set on the
battlefields of 18th century Scotland
but behind the scenes certain actors
marched to the beat of Their Own Drum
and to go by their own schedule take for
example the horse who didn't feel like
waiting until the scene was finished to
take care of personal business
quite enough
[Music]
The Lone Ranger Disney's attempt to
reboot the Lone Ranger was also an
attempt to revive the old school big
screen Western as a result Army Hammer
and Johnny Depp spend large portions of
the movie on Horseback all that time
together led to what looks like an onset
romance or at least a crush
I love you you have traveled
you have traveled far
[Music]
um
okay don't come see if I care
Anchorman
in this ridiculous classic Anchorman
Will Ferrell's character one burgundy
winds up a shell of a man located in
well I'm in a glass case of emotion and
it's all because he threw a burrito out
the window and hit a biker who responded
by punting Ron's beloved dog Baxter off
a bridge but behind the scenes it
appears the actor playing Baxter could
sense to Danger ahead because I will
give you a wrap on the Jack Johnson you
hear me all right now this is gonna
happen
yep he doesn't like you
and commandoah the beginning of
Anchorman 2 shows Ron getting the old
news team from Anchorman back together
he finds Paul Rudd's character Ace
reporter Brian fantana working as a
highly esteemed kitten photographer but
some on the set tension between the
models may have led to some well
catfights
the interview German Shepherds are one
of the most fearsome breeds of dog
liable to maim murder and dismember if
they're trained that way or apparently
that rage can be redirected and
fortunately for Seth Rogen in the
interview the scenes he shot with an
extremely friendly German Shepherd also
acquired nudity
foreign
The Hangover dogs are essentially
professional people lickers while
filming The Hangover zaka Galifianakis
established a very special bond with a
dog named Tucker although it doesn't
seem like it was always the dog he was
doing the licking
The Proposal you'd think acting opposite
Oscar wedding movie star and America's
sweetheart Sandra Bullock would get
actors to behave professionally and keep
a laser focus on their scene partner
apparently not all actors
my mind
Late Night with Conan O'Brien drawing a
taping of an episode of his old NBC show
in 2007 Conan O'Brien brought out a duck
without a plan as to what to do with it
well the duck had his own idea
and we don't even have an idea for him I
just like
the bit was so well received that
O'Brien brought the duck back naming him
quackers the teething duck it's a
relatively cushy job that seems to pay
pretty well but that doesn't mean being
a movie star isn't hard work
multi-million dollar Productions rely on
an actor's ability to you know Act so
there's a lot of pressure for them to do
a good job and not everyone is great
Under Pressure an actor Will
occasionally for whatever reason forget
their lines and they all flub in
different ways they also deal with the
embarrassment differently and oftentimes
hilariously here are some famous actors
who were caught messing up their
dialogue Lawrence Fishburne bathroom
humor is the great human equalizer be it
The Young and the old the rich and the
poor or the smart and the dumb both
oscar-nominated and non-oscar-nominated
actor alike can get behind a good butt
reference which is precisely what
happened on the set of the 2016 science
fiction film passengers in a very wordy
scene Lawrence Fishburne who plays the
spaceship's chief deck officer briefs
supposed to be hibernating passengers
Chris Pratt and Jennifer Lawrence on the
crafts movements he ends up giving us a
lesson in space Anatomy instead Jupiter
okay Uranus
and then Along Came
Bradley Cooper messing up lines will
usually cause an actor to break
character laugh lightly curse get back
to their Mark and give it another try
but some actors are just too cool for
that
um
maybe not that cool but Hangover actor
Bradley Cooper can give us a master
course on what to do when you flub your
lines during a rooftop monologue what
happens here tonight may as well never
happen never happened never happened
just fake it till you make it even if
that means that you have to speak in
gibberish
Christina Applegate in Will Ferrell and
Adam McKay's Anchorman a silly spoof of
a horrendously sexist 70s workplace
Christina Applegate plays the glass
ceiling shattering news anchor Veronica
Corningstone
[Music]
open hostility from other members of the
channel 4 news team including Sports guy
champ kind played by David keckner and
reporter Brian fantana played by Paul
Rudd inside source tells me that the FBI
has been called in to Aid in this
ongoing investigation
who am I it would be hard for anyone to
act under those circumstances
pull Rod the comedy films of Judd apito
maintain an almost impossible balance
between strong Earnest characters and
over-the-top Ridiculousness the 40 year
old virgin has its serious and heartfelt
moments but it's during one of these the
Paul Rudd slips up while pronouncing the
name of a famous painter if you love
Trish you can't do this but you gotta
finish waxing your chest because you
look like Edvard Munch The Scream yeah
sorry Ben Stiller it seems like pretty
much every romantic comedy ever made has
some variation of the don't get on that
plain speech in the 2004 Ben Stiller
Jennifer Aniston film Along Came Polly
is no exception when it comes time for
stellaton Valley's true feelings he
can't quite remember the specifics of
this particular romantic monologue you
go off to Tanzania or Cincinnati or
wherever you're going
songs
you
you I can't see you
Timothy Dalton you've got to be smooth
in order to play James Bond and Timothy
Dalton succeeded at being the ultra cool
super spy for two movies back in the
late 1980s years later he took on the
role of the villain in the Simon Pegg
cop spoof Hot Fuzz betraying his 007
image of calm and cool I think the
storm's security footage
well that's all mildly amusing what
happened next was golden still rolling
okay
Mila Kunis in Forgetting Sarah Marshall
Jason Siegel plays Peter bred up who is
as you could probably guess trying to
get his old girlfriend Sarah Marshall
you know what she's a plain Jane and she
should go back to where she came from
that is the mother of mine beta Breda
retreats to a resort where he gets over
Sarah with the help of a resort staffer
played by Mila Kunis initially Kunis's
character has to call him Mr breder but
she just can't seem to get it right
oh Mr Brenner Mr Braden brother I said
breader
Rob wriggle in the real world it's
pretty absurd for one grown man to stare
down another grown man and tell him that
he's going to hurt him it's doubly
absurd to have to do this with a comedy
Legend like Will Ferrell I'm gonna take
this I'm gonna drive it into your temple
prepare yourself for a fight a fight
that's come I don't want that
unlocked Will Ferrell we definitely want
more
Harrison Ford
the explosion of the first death star is
supposed to be a moment of Triumph for
Han Solo and the rebel forces followed
by celebration and exaltations all that
celebrating is supposed to be followed
by some lines but Harrison Ford totally
Blanks on what those lines are supposed
to be
you
that
eating your mic is definitely one way to
go Rogue Everyone likes Paul Rudd he
might be the perfect movie star he leads
a hit Marvel franchise yet he seems down
to earth he broke through in the classic
90s teen comedy clueless before becoming
one of the comedy cool kids with wet Hot
American Summer and Anchorman before
segwaying into superhero mode is Ant-Man
Rudd likes to laugh and keep it light so
it's no surprise that he generates a lot
of bloopers and to offer hilarious proof
we've taken a deep dive to bring you
some of the funniest moments from behind
the scenes of his biggest movies
just some kids stuff what makes little
kids freak out in a good way more than
anything else being present for stuff
they think they're not supposed to see
for example bad words they've been told
their entire lives that some words must
never be said so it only stands to
reason that when they actually hear one
they become enthusiastically amused like
in this outtake from Ant-Man
she got it I heard you I heard
why robot Judd Apatow likes to keep
things loose and collaborative on his
sets and since Paul Rudd has an agile
comic mind he's wound up in a few of
Apatow's movies including the 40 year
old virgin his character works alongside
Steve Carell's at a big box electronics
store which gives the actors plenty of
opportunity to play with Goofy Gadgets
in this not quite appropriate for the
final cut sequence Rudd interrupts a
conversation to show off a cool robot
toy check it out man new Robo sapiens
foreign
Black Market Panther in Anchorman a
movie full of hilarious sequences one of
the best occurs when Ace 1970 San Diego
reporter and self-proclaimed Ladies Man
Brian fantana shows off his stash of
intoxicating colognes to Ron Burgundy
the prize of his collection Sex Panther
they've done studies you know
60 of the time it works every time
that doesn't make sense this outtake the
elaborate panther-shaped mechanical prop
doesn't work at all
enter
13 000 that really pisses me off
knocking a few Back to the Future
pretending to be intoxicated improvising
lines and doing either of those things
while a co-star is angrily yelling into
your ear can't be easy but Rudd manages
all three of those tasks in this unused
scene from Knocked Up while his
character gets progressively more drunk
in a restaurant he slurs and stumbles
through some Back to the Future themed
goofing I'm gonna build you know what
I'm gonna build I'm gonna build you a
skateboard I want to see what you do in
the Town Square
can you hear me in the future trust me
I'm going to drop it go to the Twins Oak
Small that used to be the Hill Valley
Hill Valley
cracking up is only natural
the 2012 comedy Wanderlust concerns a
big city couple so sick of urban
annoyances that they decide to try life
on a nature positive free love hippie
style commune in this outtake Paul Rudd
tries to convince Jennifer Aniston that
they need to give up the natural life I
don't think we're supposed to be in a
place where people are hairier than Alec
Baldwin's forearms
many apologies Mr bold
rolling right along in the 2008 comedy
Role Models Paul Rudd and Sean William
Scott play a couple of guys forced into
community service all that stress
highlights the differences between the
two resulting in a fight which created a
few unusable outtakes this come up this
this this coming from a guy who who
likes girls a whole bunch
foreign
to call cut in 2010 Rudd starred
opposite Reese Witherspoon in how do you
know where he plays a nice guy named
George who gets caught up in a federal
investigation of his father's company he
also finds time to Fall in Love George
is more than a bit nervous and judging
by this blooper those traits seeped into
Rudd's psyche I'm gonna tell you exactly
I'm going to let out everything that I
have inside oh kiss from Kiss
nuts to you what a schmuck Dinner for
Schmucks is an odd comedy about odd
people it stars Rudd as a guy caught up
with a strange club that requires guests
to bring an oddball along to regular
dinner parties his candidate is a weirdo
named Barry played by Steve Carell while
shooting one particular scene things got
slightly weirder than expected
popcorn's ready
I was just I was just microwaving some
hot pockets stranger things has plenty
of scares but there are laughs too some
of the funniest moments were totally
unintentional which actors couldn't stop
laughing during takes keep watching for
the best stranger things bloopers
in the season 3 episode the caves of the
missing lifeguard will played by Noah
schnapper decides to wake up his friends
Mike and Lucas in a rather unusual way
dressed in a purple wizard outfit will
press his play on his cassette player
which turned up to an annoyingly high
volume starts playing a funny medieval
flute song annoyed by his circus act
Mike and Lucas beg will to stop the
music and let them be and here comes a
part that didn't come out quite right on
the first try instead of saying I have
seen into the future and I have seen
that today is a new day a day free of
girls schnapper couldn't stop saying
another version of the line and I have
seen that today is a new day
a day full of girls
in one episode from season two actor
Caleb McLaughlin who plays Lucas
Sinclair finds himself having to enter a
classroom with his back slamming against
the door walkie-talkie in hand once
inside he's faced with having to answer
to an angry elderly teacher for
disturbing her class as soon as
McLaughlin turns around he's greeted by
an off-screen Voice who asks if he hurts
himself
Excuse Me Miss no
reset
McLaughlin seems to be having the most
fun during filming and we all know that
if you love your job you'll never have
to work a day in your life
in a beloved bit from season 3 featuring
Finn wolfhard as Mike wheeler and Millie
Bobby Brown as 11 an extremely awkward
and blinded by love Mike tries to tell
the girl of his dreams how he truly
feels about her a scene takes place in a
supermarket where they're taking Shelter
From the looming danger that awaits on
the outside and as the two characters
sitting on the floor face to face is
this a rehearsal we're rolling hell yeah
hi editors and what's editor wouldn't be
happy about seeing a personalized
greeting from Finn wolfhard himself
while sifting through hours of endless
footage
being tasked with containing the other
wealthy events that transpired in The
Stranger Things Universe we can all
agree that Dr Sam Owens is a man who
carries a tremendous burden on his
shoulders in a scene from season two's
well the wise at the Paul Riser enters a
room wearing his glorious love goats
turns to actor Natalia Daya and Charlie
Heaton and is supposed to say it's not
very pleasant in here is it it's not
very pleasant in here it is
no wonder this became one of the show's
best blooper moments after all the man
is a natural-born comedian
the character of world bias has engraved
himself in our hearts as a soft-spoken
well-mannered gentle boy who would never
hurt a soul well unless he was possessed
by the Mind flayer in season 2 episode
The pollywog schnapping co-star Finn
wolfhard who plays Mike are staring down
at Dustin's trap worried about the very
angry creature inside there's a
frightened look in their eyes and in an
attempt to express his shock snap tries
to gasp but instead this is what came
out
oh my gosh
in season two's the Mind player Dustin
Henderson played by Gayton Matarazzo
finds himself having to run towards a
ringing phone in order to pick it up and
slam it back down on the receiver but in
one particular I'll take he fails to do
so multiple times smashing the phone
against the wall while trying and
failing to hang it up
[Music]
when will buyers disappears and is
presumed dead Hawkins middle school has
a moment to say a few brief words in his
memory a scene takes place in a school's
gym and does all of Will's close friends
and attendance but their grief is not
shared by students Troy Walsh and James
Dante as they disrespectfully mug the
boy who most people assumed has passed
away Mike decides to confront the boys
for their behavior while the rest of the
school is leaving the gym and pushes
Troy to the crown Troy then decides to
attack Mike but is stopped in his tracks
by 11 played by Millie Bobby Brown who
uses her powers to make him pee himself
in front of everyone and that's when
another kid takes the opportunity to
make Troy the butt of the joke by saying
dude Troy peed himself but that's not
what we get in the blooper
struggling to keep ourselves together
while being terrorized by the thought
that she might never see her son again
Joyce buyers played by Winona Ryder
often finds herself entering into a mode
of Hysteria in season 2 Joyce and Baba
facing two government officials in
uniform the authority figures are in
full listening mode as the desperate
mother loses her ability to construct a
sentence which is more the result of
Rider totally flubbing her line and
grasping for the next word
in the season 2 episode The Lost sister
eleven sets out on a quest to find a
group of unruly outcasts including a
strange but powerful girl who's later
unveiled as Kali Prasad also known as
eight eleven meets up with Becky Ives to
look through some files hoping to learn
more information about other children
the Hawkins lab has experimented on it's
here that 11 learns that Kali was
kidnapped in England as a child it's
also hear that Millie Bobby Brown got
whacked over the head
in episode 1 of season 3 Hawkins chief
of police Jim Hopper played by David
Harbor sits 11 and Mike down in order to
tell Mike that something has happened to
his grandma in the actual scene which is
somehow disturbing and funny in itself
Hopper says your mom called she needs
you home right away it's your grandma
sounds simple enough right nope far from
it it's your grandma
[Music]
yeah
no no I don't think so
a few takes in Harbor began defending
himself saying the word is so funny when
it comes to the most thought about
bloopers and stranger things history
this is the one that takes a proverbial
cake the official stranger things
writer's room Twitter account dedicated
a couple of tweets to honor the special
moments with one of them reading Legend
has it that David K Harbor still can't
say Grandma without laughing as it turns
alsis is also one of The Duffer Brothers
favorite bloopers of the show
nothing there's nothing wrong with Nana
what